[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir m'entendais bien
alors on va commencer par une petite
question qui pense que les français sont
des râleurs
hockey une bonne partie de la salle et
maintenant qui est français
je vous ferais bien je fais pas partie
du service de l'immigration dont vous
faut et tous levé la main
ok donc six récapitule
presque toute la salle pense que les
français sont des râleurs et parce que
toute la salle et française au moins je
sais que si vous râlez à la fin de mon
taux que bon je serai pourquoi en
réalité il n'ya pas besoin d'être
français pour être un valeur c'est un
sport qui se pratique partout dans le
monde et en fait je trouve que l'homme a
une tendance naturelle à voir toujours
le verre à moitié vide plutôt qu'à
moitié plein alors si vous êtes un
râleur vous même ou si vous connaissez
quelqu'un qui les écoutaient
attentivement ce qui va suivre parce que
je vous donnais une technique pour
toujours voir la vie du bon côté et
cette technique s'appelle la destituer
mais avant cela je vous demandais tous
pendant 10 secondes à peu près de
sourire souriez à vos voisins voilà vous
fait sourire vraiment vous allez voir ça
va vous mettre dans de bonnes
dispositions pour les minutes qui vont
suivre
c'est bon tout le monde a souri
tant mieux
parce qu'effectivement quand on regarde
les médias bah c'est compliqué de
sourire
qu'ovide
réchauffement climatique guérir
inflation même kim kardashian et kanye
west divorce mais où va le monde
et tous à matraquer en permanence dans
nos têtes
évidemment c'est bien rajouter un peu de
ce biais confirmation naturel que nous
avons
et finalement les peurs s'accumulent au
lieu de se succéder tout nous pousse à
croire que tout va mal tout nous pousse
à être dans la déprime la plus totale
tout nous pousse à aller vers cette
issue fatale
hees a pas qu'en france partout dans le
monde il est donc important il est
urgent de comprendre que finalement nos
vies ne dépendent pas tant des
événements extérieurs mais plutôt de
latitude que nous avons face à l une des
premières attitude à avoir c'est
véritablement de
regarder les choses factuellement
dans le livre fac foule nes on peut
comprendre que finalement quand on
regarde d'un point de vue macro le monde
ne s'est jamais sentie aussi mieux
qu'aujourd'hui si on met le
réchauffement climatique de côté
évidemment et cette année marque le 10e
anniversaire du rapport sur le bonheur
dans le monde est contre toute attente
il se trouve que finalement l'année
dernière a été une année très heureuse
même les français ont été des plus
heureux ont enfin été plus heureux que
d'habitude c'est pour vous dire
peut-être avons-nous compris que
finalement nos petits tracas du
quotidien n'était pas si simple si
important
en fait l'année dernière il ya une
véritable pandémie de bienveillance
alors si nous profitions de cette
pandémie pour changer un peu notre
regard sur la vie
si nous profitons de ce moment pour
changer et le faire des lib a
délibéremment pour pouvoir regarder le
verre à moitié plein et ainsi vivre une
vie pleinement épanouie et si nous
passions tout simplement en mode beast
itude
pour moi
une des personnes qui représentent le
plus la bastide c'est barack obama
il connaît ses émotions il peut rire il
peut pleurer s'agacer non seulement il
connaît ses émotions dans plus il les
maîtrise il n'a pas peur et n'essayez
pas de les refouler et au président des
états unis qu'il fût il reste accessible
il était doté d'une grande intelligence
émotionnelle
alors si tout le monde ne peut pas être
président quoique
tout le monde peut adopter la destituer
dans sa vie au quotidien
alors même dire oui ok d'accord mais
c'est quoi cette fameuse veste itude et
bien sûr relativement simple la
destituer est une manière de se tenir et
se comporter correspondants et neut
dispositions psychologiques
positive qui va vous permettre de
toujours vous présenté souriant confiant
et bienveillant
l'a destitué est une philosophie qui
peut s'appliquer à tout le monde quel
que soit votre revenu ou de votre niveau
social vos habitudes ou encore votre
niveau d'éducation
en somme la béatitude c'est être soi
même ainsi de faire ressortir le
meilleur de soi
alors l'idée n'est pas de s'inventer un
personnage imaginaire ça ne tiendrait
pas dans la durée au contraire c'est
vraiment de poser les choses simplement
se regarder dans un miroir et se dire
honnêtement ce que l'on pense de soi est
ce que finalement on est cette personne
que nos amis appellent quand ils ont
besoin de nous est-ce qu'on est cette
personne qui cherche en permanence des
solutions plutôt que voir les problèmes
est ce que finalement nous sommes sept
personnes qui sommes capables de nous
battre pour nos opinions
prenez par exemple quand vous savez une
mauvaise journée est ce que vous faites
partie des gens qui les répercutent leur
mauvaise humeur sur leurs proches ou
est-ce qu'au contraire vous essayez de
les préserver
voyez finalement la baisse' titus est
assez simple c'est une attitude ou d'en
laisser d'être positive donner le
meilleur de soi sourire parce que ça
fait du bien
et en le faisant progressivement tous
les jours vous verrez que naturellement
votre comportement va changer et vous
verrez même fait les autres qui est en
mode destitue des qui ne l'est pas
et naturellement vous allez vous
orienter vers les personnes qui sont
plus positives alors je vois bien un
certain sceptiques vont me dire oui ok
la méthode coué ça va on ne peut pas
toujours être positive
et ils auront raison
on a tous des problèmes en revanche avec
le temps j'ai compris que
ruminer en permanence ne les fait pas
disparaître donc c'est pour ça que
j'adopte cette position positive
et vous
est-ce que vous présentez toujours sous
le meilleur jour
et pourquoi ne le feriez vous pas pour
info quand on sourit à ce qu'on a fait
au début eh bien on fait baisser le taux
de d'hormones enfin la production
d'hormones négative savez tels que le
cortisol ou encore l'adrénaline et en
même temps ça fait augmenter
drastiquement l'endorphine et la
dopamine savez ces fameuses hormones du
bonheur
et quand on sait que finalement rire et
qu'on est positif et communicatif
pourquoi s'en priver
alors finalement la vie c'est
relativement simple c'est un peu comme
un film ni un début il y a une fin et au
milieu il ya une histoire
grosso modo on a tous la même vie tous
les mêmes étape dans la vie
de la naissance jusqu'à la mort pour
repousser la même chose c'est donc à
vous de voir si vous voulez faire de
cette histoire
une comédie un drame ou une aventure
épique
aujourd'hui la bonne nouvelle c'est que
vous et nous sommes le réalisateur de
notre propre vie
j'ai une croyance profonde me dis que
finalement notre attitude peut être
notre meilleure amie ou notre meilleur
ennemi
et en fonction de ça eh bien on peut
voir effectivement si on est en mode
beast études ou pas
en fait n'est pas obligés de me croire
évidemment
donc j'ai fait une petite étude j'ai
même une longue étude une étude sur près
de 50 ans
et cette étude chez vous la livrer ce
soir en exclusivité
c'est une étude une étude unique en son
genre puisqu'elle ne comporte qu'un
participant moi
alors je vais faire passer rapidement
les étapes de cette mystique de cette
étude mais juste avant je vous donnais
la conclusion
de vivre de façon positive nous
apportera une vie plus épanouie simple
je répète vivent de façon positive vous
apportera une fille plus épanouie
basique
allez on y va donc à ma naissance
je n'ai dans une île vous voyez où ils
en rêvent de partir en vacances
et au bout d'un an j'atterris comme
beaucoup de mes enfants d'ouvriers dans
une cité hlm en région parisienne pas de
chance je pas né sous la bonne étoile
entre cinq et dix ans
je me rends compte progressivement que
ma couleur de peau mon prénom mes
origines sociales on handicap à l'oeil
et les goûts vestimentaires de ma mère
ne vont pas m'aider dans la vie
chaque jour
mes petits camarades en classe se moque
de moi
et chaque nuit
dans ma chambre je pleure en me
demandant pourquoi
alors j'ai beau essayer de leur faire
changer le regard sur moi mais ils sont
trop nombreux trop narquois
je me retourne donc vers la seule chose
que je peux éventuellement modifier ma
propre perception de moi et là je me dis
que moi aussi j'ai le droit de vivre
heureux
aujourd'hui pas demain qu'il est donc
maintenant temps de prendre en main mon
destin
alors entre 10 ans et 20 ans déterminé à
battre tous types déterminisme
je rencontre quelques succès je souhaite
une classe ça gonfle mon estime de moi
et ça c'est classe
je remporte un certain nombre de
compétitions je découvre l'excellence je
deviens
jeu j'aime le dépassement de moi et je
dis stop à la victimisation
je rencontre la première copine et petit
à petit je perde ma timidité la
virginité avec ma voisine
mais pendant cette période d'adolescence
nous rend compte aussi quelque chose
c'est que finalement l'amour fait mal
surtout quand il est unilatérale
je rencontre aussi que j'ai beau être né
en france mais que je ne serai jamais
français dans les yeux des personnes
étriqué
auront aussi que gagner des médailles
c'est bien mais qu'il faut que je
continue à apprendre si je ne peux pas
rester sur le bord du chemin
alors un jour tout s'arrête à 19 ans
la mort cogné à la porte ou plutôt la
fenêtre
pneumonie septicémie et plein d'autres
termes que je n'ai pas bien compris me
plonge pendant 30 10 jours dans le coma
à mon réveil
une trachéotomie m'empêche de parler
des tuyaux dans les pouilles nous
empêchent de respirer c'est tellement
mal que je n'ai plus qu'une seule envie
fermez les yeux et dire au revoir à la
vie
il a
je pense à mon petit frère joakim
pour lui je suis un héros et je me dis
que je ne peux pas battre perdre cette
guerre je pense aussi à ma mère qui va
venir me voir demain pour son
anniversaire
et il est clair que je ne capitulerait
pas face à cet adversaire
enfin je pense à moi il ya tout ce que
j'ai vécu jusque là et il est hors de
question que je baisse les bras
alors d'un coup
demande aux infirmiers de me sortir de
mon lit de m'habiller dignement de me
mettre à 6
pour montrer à ma mère et à mes amis que
je vais me battre pour montrer à mon
père
qui aime le mari utiliser de sourire
pour combattre est ce ce jour précis de
ma vie que j'ai compris que la baisse'
titude m'aidera toujours à vivre
épanouie
à 26 ans je gagne beaucoup d'argent mais
flanque tout rapidement et un peu
bêtement
évidemment quand on n'en a pas eu avant
on n'a pas forcément l'attitude d'un
gérant
mais finalement avec ou sans argent ce
qui reste constant c'est que la coop
police continue à me contrôler aussi
fréquemment
et dans la vie du travail le monde du
travail ce n'est pas plus réjouissant je
comprends que
à
qualité égale
celui qui est normal ne passera toujours
devant
ma vue baisse
j'ai quelques malades 1 10 quelques
accidents mais finalement j'ai plus de
vies qu'un chat et sans devient marrant
et alors que j'avais prêté serment pour
la vie
eh bien je divorce pour être
jeudi soir c'est toujours un peu
compliqué jeudi commence
pour ne pas vieillir prématurément
alors la moralité de cette décennie
c'est qu'il ya des hauts et des bas dans
la vie
et la vie
vous réserve des surprises parfois à 35
ans de jumeaux jeu devient papa d'un
enfant je passe directement à 3 mais la
vie est bien faite je peux me préparer
pendant neuf mois sauf que
pressé de me voir ils débarquent en
grands prémas dans la salle de
réanimation
je me souvienne l'humour non papa et je
dis à mon fils rodrigues tu verras ça
ira
avec toute notre énergie positive
il s'en sortira il s'en sortir on est en
effet à maury et alexandre
s'en sont sortis
en revanche je ne comprends pas pourquoi
l'un voit toujours le verre à moitié
vide et l'autre est toujours aussi
intrépide
comment deux êtres qui sont nés en même
temps peuvent être à tel point si
différent
pour comprendre à 40 ans je lis tous les
livres sur la pensée positive
jean a même au niveau européen une
grande initiative
j'entreprends de démontrer que la
béatitude peut s'appliquer aussi bien
dans la vie d'entreprise que dans sa vie
perso bingo
les employés épanouie sont plus
productifs au boulot
parce que toute ma vie toute ma carrière
j'ai vu des gens
se perdent beaucoup de personnes
vivant dans la vie d'un autre
jusqu'au dégoût
beaucoup de personnes s'interdisant de
rêver
pour rester dans une pseudo normalité
alors je décide de mettre toute mon
énergie pour aider les autres pour faire
en sorte que jamais quelqu'un ne vive la
vie d'un autre
mais c'était sans compter que la vie est
parfois joueuses
dans la même année
une ami un collègue et georges klein
rencontre la faucheuse cette même année
cette même année la pandémie est
ravageuse
je n'y arrive plus je n'ai plus la même
joueuse
et alors que toute ma vie j'avais
réussi des eaux la main les épreuves
je n'y arrive plus je sens inutile
incapable de dire balle 9
à 46 ans
fatigué de ce monde injuste qui
m'entoure je m'effondre
désabusé
chaque jour chaque nuit je passe mon
temps à me morfondre
alors je me dis comme à 6 ans que
à la fille la vie est cruelle
et comme un 19 ans je me dis que c'est
sans doute pour ça qu'elle est plus
belle
alors
lis que je vais pas craquer maintenant
c'est vraiment pas le moment
non je craquerais pas je craquerais pas
je craquerais pas
j'entends encore tellement de choses à
faire tellement de belles choses à vivre
je suis à peine au moins à la moitié de
la quête que j'avais entrepris de
poursuivre et des temps de jean ma
famille mes amis des amis de ma famille
et d un maximum de personnes à vivre
complètement épanoui
alors une fois encore
je décide de changer d'attitude
et une nouvelle fois je fais appel à la
baisse' titude
si je partage avec vous ses quelques
verres c'est finalement la vie c'est
comme un verre à moitié vide à moitié
plein on ne peut pas choisir son destin
moi j'ai décidé de voir toujours la vie
comme un verre à moitié plein
et maintenant je suis arrivé à la moitié
de ma vie
entouré de ma famille mes amis ma
compagne et de sa fille
je peux vous assurer que jusqu'à la fin
de mes jours
j'appliquerai la baisse' titube encore
et toujours
voilà vous savez ce qu'elle investit
tude c'est une attitude simple et
puissante pour voir la vie du bon côté
et vivre pleinement épanouie
avant de vous quitter je voudrais
remercier sincèrement toutes les
personnes qui m'ont mis des coups dans
ma vie
vraiment grâce à elle j'ai été plus fort
j'étais plus résilient grâce à elle j'ai
pu voir la vie à moitié plein enfin
grâce à elle j'ai apprécié chaque moment
de ma vie et je compte bien continuer à
le faire parce que la vie est courte et
on en a qu'une et enfin je voudrais vous
remercier vous oui vous aurez vous
remercier par avance parce qu'en fait
vous demander un service ce que je veux
pas y arriver seul
seulement d une seule une chose et une
seule
je vous demandais à mes d2 mais des
pardons essayer de transformer ce monde
vers lequel n'oublie sont dangereusement
et doucement je vais vous demander de
m'aider
à faire en sorte que le monde virtuel
que nous vivons dans lequel
là
pardon la haine de son prochain et la
peur du lendemain prennent le pas sur la
bienveillance et l'optimisme alors une
chose une seule je vous demandais ce
soir dès ce soir oui d'envoyer un
message à quelqu'un de votre entourage
pour lui dire tout ce que vous pensez
bien
je peux compter sur vous
à une dernière une dernière chose
n'oubliez pas à la fin de votre meta
message de m #fb stud
merci
[Applaudissements]